good morning
well last evening we had two very sad
moments of silence yesterday
for 800 000 people who have died from
covet we had moment of silence on the
floor of the house but also on the steps
of the capital and bipartisan
house and senate
remembrance of those who lost their
lives
our thoughts and prayers are with their
families
and those who have lost their
livelihoods as well
but the deaths are
so very very sad it's so hard to
comprehend
800 000 people
and the number continues to grow
but we
continue to be optimistic about
the effectiveness of the vaccines
the awareness that some people are
coming to that they need to be
vaccinated
they need to be vaccinated
and
then we also had the moment of silence
for those who are affected by the storms
i was very uh moved by representative
comers
who represents western kentucky as he
spoke calling for a moment of silence
about those who lost their lives
i talked to him after and he
was going to be traveling with the
president today so far they're pleased
with police who can be pleased but
have uh
received
the federal response that is necessary
and talked to my former chairman of the
probation committee mr rogers he knows
what we can do and uh
i'm sure that if there's more that
congress needs to do he will inform us
of that
he told me that the storm the
it was a mile wide the phenomenon was a
mile wide and with such force
so very sad
yesterday was a busy day for us
legislatively
as you know we uh
passed a resolution
against racism in our society uh the
and
establishing a special counsel at the
department of state to fight
islamophobia to
talking about the numbers incidents
against
muslims in our country
uh
in terms of
anti-muslim
sentiments we also passed the weaker
bill
which calls about china to end what they
are doing there i mean that's genocide
it's genocide in china
the uh
interest though in it across our country
is about the human rights aspect of it
but also the forced labor piece of it
when
the
president xi
brings these people into these forced
labor camps and separating them from
their families and
and taking other drastic actions he is
also engaging them in forced labor and
that is something that we cannot have
our businesses compete with so from a
moral standpoint a value standpoint the
legislation was very important and from
a trade standpoint essential as well
the big bench for us yesterday of course
was the debt limit
to lift the debt limit it's just always
so
interesting to me that
not the republicans vote against lifting
the debt
the debt limit the ceiling on the debt
limit it is something that um
threatens our the financial security of
our country is is
gambles with the personal financial
security of families
and again the health of our economy as
well as its impact globally
it's one thing to say well we'll have a
few votes against it to make a statement
it's another thing to say we shouldn't
be doing it and that's what they did
yesterday just so people know how it
affects them of course it has a big
impact
millions of jobs lost trillions of
dollars of household wealth down the
drain
and again the
cost to you if you have a car loan a
credit card bill a
school loan any
interest that you're paying on a loan
will be increased if in fact we did not
lift the debt ceiling the constitution
says the full faith and credit of the
united states should not be questioned
but in addition to that
even the discussion of it a few years
ago lowered the interest rate
the interest of
our credit rating the united states
credit rating and that was not a good
thing for our economy we should not be
flirting with danger when it comes to
our economy whether it's our national
economy or global economy or the
personal
well financial well-being of america's
working families
i want to commend going back to rehearse
for a moment uh chairman george excuse
me
not george my covering
he gets confused with george mcgovern on
the on the on the uh
food security issues but jim mcgovern
really
are really a patron saint to us in terms
of fighting for human rights throughout
the world and the swiger bill on forced
labor was his legislation yesterday
neglected to mention that
when i talked about that
and so now we are
just trying to see how
soon we can
pass to build back better legislation so
important it has fraught with meaning at
this time because on today the 15th of
december would be the last
biden child tax credit check that would
go out
uh we're hoping that we can have this
settled
before christmas because on december
31st
this expires and
so it's essential
that what we see in terms of the tax
creditism has been used
more recently for
preparing children for school
it's been used for food
for rent it's essential essentials
that the child tax credit has been used
60 million children benefit a large
number of them
off of poverty coming out of poverty
because of the child tax credit
so for this and other reasons
everything to do with children child
care
universal pre-k affordable at making
child care affordable i guess the best
two words to use
build back better i mean i've said it's
transformative and all that but the best
two words to use those it lowers cost it
lowers cost of child care it lowers cost
of health care it lowers cost of food it
lowers costs in so many ways that are
essential to america's working families
the very issues that people struggle
over the kitchen table to figure out how
we're going to pay the bills the very
issues very
frightening things that people have
trying to go to sleep at night how we're
going to pay the bills well build back
better helps you to do that
we love the fact that it's build back
better with women build back better for
the children build back better for the
planet lowering energy cost
again it lowers costs so hopefully
the senate will deal with that and send
that to us and of course we're also
hopeful that they will send us bills to
protect our democracy that respects the
sanctity of the vote that keeps us a
democracy so we're prepared to come back
as soon as the senate is ready to send
us these bills and it is um
it's pretty exciting uh we
the
enthusiasm that is out there for the
president's package
his vision for our country
building the infrastructure in a
bipartisan bill to do that all of us
many of us are having our
our town meetings our public events in
our
in our own regions and
the response has just been so optimistic
about how these resources
to build the infrastructure in a way
that brings
equity fairness justice to it all
in a green way that protects uh the
environment
and that again creates good paying
union jobs uh jobs that
uh again
protect the planet as we
promote
jobs as we move commerce as we
get people safely to and from school and
work without staying in the cars a long
time so it improves the quality of life
so that's for the
infrastructure bill the buildback better
enhances all of that so we're very eager
i'm very proud of that work
i i think that
there's an arrange an agreement that can
be made and i look forward to
uh
working to pass that on the house side
so that's kind of what we
we have going here oh
did i talk about steph curry i talk
about steph curry
just in the first yeah the warriors
college and first just coincidental
uh the first
few minutes i was
not by myself one other member mr payne
and i were in the cloak room
with ella and and twelve the women who
for whom i bought a hot doll to watch
the game just the two of us there first
few minutes um
settle
tied
a few minutes later break the record
with such dignity with such poise with
such discipline with such excellence and
then i had to go to work and then came
back to see the ending and to see
um miller and and jones i mean see the
other two leaders in that field be there
with their shirts well i don't have my
phone but i have the picture on my phone
of them
and then them giving
steph
the shirt with his number on it i think
we'll get to 3 000 pretty soon but no
pressure let's just win the games but it
was pretty exciting i have to say and to
see the enthusiasm
of the crowd
for for that achievement
whether the knicks fans were excited
about the game
but there was great enthusiasm for steph
curry and so we're very very
very proud of him yeah
any questions
madam speaker uh insider just completed
a five-month investigation finding that
49 members of congress and 182 senior
congressional staffers have violated the
stock act um the inside dream
i'm wondering if you have any reaction
to that and secondly you should members
of congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving in congress no i don't know to
the second one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month review but
if the people aren't reporting they
should be
because this is a free market in people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
yes ma'am speaker you talked about
voting rights uh we know senator warnock
yesterday i expressed that he would like
to see the senate state and as uh who
did senator warnock on the senate side
yesterday talked about voting rights
yesterday staying here through the
holidays to get it done uh and really
pressuring the white house and senator
manchin to uh push for maybe a similar
car as we saw for the debt ceiling do
you share
uh that sentiment and you think that
there needs to be a more sense of
urgency senator warnock's statement
yesterday was i just didn't hear what
you said
was a beautiful patriotic statement
about our country
he has been
an inspiration
all his life and now as a member of the
senate so i so i completely
am inspired by and agree with what he
said i don't know i've said i don't get
to put i don't participate that much in
senate rules discussions
but
i do know that there are three members
of the supreme court whom senator mitch
mcconnell got there with the simple
majority by taking exception to the
filibuster so if those three people can
have a job for life
affecting lives of the american people i
don't see why we couldn't have
legislation that stops the voter
suppression
making it harder for people to to vote
and also now
to end the election nullification
probably i mean with stiff competition
within their initiatives across the
country for the worst stuff companies
for the worst the election nullification
is one that has attracted
a good deal of attention because
if you're just going to say we'll have
elections and three people that we
decide who they are are going to decide
what those numbers are then you have
destroyed our democracy so i would hope
that we can make progress
in a bipartisan way
i don't know why the sanctity of the
vote the fundamental principle of our
democracy is not as important to
republicans as it is to democrats and i
support what senator warnock
was suggesting
tonight
democrats of course i hope that we go
back
months ago here we are 10 days before
christmas it's possible very likely that
if you get 120 points
did you even just calculate the
resistance from joe manchin even though
he detailed where he was months ago
no i think that
this is called the legislative process
and uh
we have our rules and they have their
rules and
it i'm still hopeful that it will pass
i'm not going to have a postmortem on
something that hasn't died uh i think
that uh
i think we will have the legislation it
will pass uh i hope the sooner the
better especially since we had certain
deadlines and uh i respect the process
and i respect center mansion
thank you the mayor of san francisco
london greed expressed concern about
crimes but it's time for the reign of
criminals to end what do you think about
some of this crime specifically in san
francisco uh smashing grabs and also
generally is there
some sort of a federal response you know
we passed prime bills here before
there's something looking at some of
these problems well specifically to what
is happening not just in san francisco
uh but in other parts of the country in
fact
a retail association of the whole
country and uh leaders in um business
across the country have asked
for a remedy and we do have one
as we are preparing uh the chip spill
for lack of another you know what i mean
when i say the chips bill the chips bill
is about chips it's about supply
chain and it's about research and we're
very close to our own agreement in the
house on that
within that bill
the energy and commerce committee has
something called inform
all caps
and that is a legislation
that would require those who are selling
online especially
to establish their
legitimacy as to where these products
came from because what people do is they
steal things and sell them online they
have to establish their legitimacy if
they're going to be
sold online and then in addition to that
that's energy and commerce the judiciary
committee has a bill safe shopping which
it addresses the same problem in a
little bit of a different way in terms
of uh
though holding
platforms accountable and those selling
things account accountable for the
provenance of those goods
and it is
you know
elsewhere out of the question that
people should be able to think that they
can just steal things
profit from them
and not have any accountability on it so
those two things
some combination of those two things
both of them are going to be in the bill
how it
you know how they come together
working with the senate to pass that
legislation and that's completely in the
works
specifically about what the mayor said
about some of the issues specific to san
francisco some of the retailers leaving
there as well well it is it's absolutely
outrageous you know obviously it cannot
continue
but the fact is that there is an
attitude of uh uh lawlessness in our
country that springs from i don't know
where
maybe you do and we cannot have that
lawlessness
become the norm
and these people have
they have
they
coordinate with each other
and they plan
traffic patterns in the rest so that
they can reach their goal and depart
very quickly and some of it is
again high level stores as
the um
retailers have told us and some of it is
your local
walgreens
but none of it
is acceptable and again
it is
it has to be stopped and again showing
that people were not being able to
profit from that this isn't like
somebody's stealing something to go home
because they don't have the money to buy
this is about
stealing for profit
they have to prove where
where where it came from it's outrageous
and it must as i agree with the mayor it
must be stopped but it's not just san
francisco
it's in it's in our entire country and
that's evidenced by the
uh appeals that we are receiving from
across the country for the legislation
so i hope that that will be soon
and for many reasons including
uh the um
the provenance of the goods yes ma'am
let's figure um looking ahead to january
6 because we may not get an opportunity
to talk to you again before then
yeah i'll probably be here tomorrow next
week are you not going to be around
is this your goodbye
[Music]
but in the event it's not i i wanted to
we went to the
uh inspector general for the capitol
police last week that a lot of the
recommendations are still open to better
that department uh coming up on a year
since january 6th how do you feel about
the the level of change at that agency
the security here at the capitol and the
security of your members as they hope to
spend their their holidays at home
well i thank you for the question i i
don't
it is my hope that this is not our last
meeting we still have to deal with the
sanctity of the vote and protecting uh
our democracy we still have to
uh
lower cost the american people by
passing ddb
and uh so hopefully we'll see you next
week but in terms of that i felt the
capital is much
for january 6
uh in terms of uh the the different
categories of strength and morale of the
police force uh the physical structure
that coming from the architect of the
capital
and uh the
so much of what is happening here is not
so much about security as is about covet
and so
we want to be able to open the capital
uh
of course we can't do that without the
consent of the capital physician and he
knows of our interest and how he thinks
we could do that soon so the fact that
we don't have as many tours and all the
rest is not necessarily a security issue
it's a covet issue uh but uh whenev this
is a horizon we are always working to do
better with security and we do have
those conversations are ongoing and
we'll have some accounting of it before
the january 6th
would you consider a standalone piece of
legislation just for the child tax
credit because you have a deadline where
the irs won't be able to send out
january's payment on time this month
well it's going to be going out today
this month january entertainment or
january oh you said this month
they have said that they need it done by
the fight
just a question of what of course we
could pass that in the house whether we
could pass it in the senate remains to
be seen but i don't want to let anybody
off the hook on the bbb to say well we
covered that one thing so now the
pressure is off i think that that is
really important leverage in a
discussion on bbb that the children and
their families will suffer without that
payment not everybody gets it on a
monthly basis but those who need it the
most do
and so uh
we're just still optimistic about bbb
passing and uh
uh
perhaps even if it were after the first
of the year which i hope it is not that
it could be retroactive if it's early
enough in the first
thank you all very much i i was i said
to my colleagues last night
i hope i see you next week
but if i don't
marry everything merry christmas happy
belated hanukkah mary everything happy
new year happy holidays but we really
are hoping very much to be back here
next week
and by then steph will be close to three
thousand
three thousand i have to say when i
announced it to my colleagues
some were very excited and others were
like the next lost
lighten up next
thank you all bye-bye
yes